el presidente Argentina Alberto
Fernández continúa su gira por Estados
Unidos luego derribar el domingo el
recorrido siguió en la sede Naciones
Unidas donde tuvo un encuentro con el
secretario general Antonio Gutiérrez
sobre la mesa estuvieron los problemas
globales pero también un asunto
trascendental para la política Argentina
la soberanía de las Islas malvinas
me reuní con el secretario general de la
ONU Antonio Gutiérrez analizamos los
desafíos de la coyuntura internacional y
les reiteré la solicitud de la Argentina
de reanudar las negociaciones para
encontrar una pronta y pacífica solución
a la disputa de soberanía sobre malvinas
este miércoles Fernández se verá con el
presidente de Estados Unidos Joe biden
en el marco de la celebración por los
200 años de relaciones bilaterales la
Casa Blanca ha catalogado a Argentina
como un Aliado clave en la región si
bien no hay agenda confirmada la
inmigración en América el cambio
climático y la guerra en Ucrania se
prueben como los asuntos principales
Fernández Espera que esto profundice Los
lazos con Washington
que progresemos en nuestro vínculo con
los Estados Unidos
ya tenemos una agenda definida
hablar de todo el ministro de economía
argentino Sergio massa también estará en
la reunión con biden desde Buenos Aires
buscan el respaldo estadounidense de
Cara a la cuarta revisión del programa
de facilidades extendidas del fondo
monetario internacional una le
permitiría Argentina recibir 5.300
millones de dólares un monto necesario
en un contexto económico delicado